said that this was the worst file he's
ever seen in Bridgeport Connecticut
in the fourth murder state of the United
States my case is the worst he's ever
seen
that's a big deal
okay
all right Eve hi Eve where are you from
originally where'd you grow up Trumbull
Connecticut
tell me about your family growing up
um you got a good childhood
I my parents
had me when my dad was 19 and my mother
was 17. they are both from Trumbull they
met in Trumbull High and
um no my father was a drug addict
um my mother was an alcoholic you know
we were 70s kids I have two younger
sisters so we were just like feral
children exers
played outside from morning to night you
know took our baths in the kiddie pool
kind of thing
um and my parents didn't really do much
parenting I was the oldest and my
sisters are
four and five years younger than me so I
was basically the mom and dad and yeah
childhood sucked and we lived in the
basement of my grandparent parents house
in Trumbull the house that I still live
in to this very day
the house for the home invasion took
place that I'll be talking about today
um and yeah that was our childhood and
my mother
um raised us with the wooden spoon and a
Bible
in the Baptist Church so it was pretty
interesting
a lot of physical
and mental abuse a lot from both of my
parents
did any of that play a part in what
happened to you
no no no no no no that is really
consequential yeah I had nothing to do
with it but it's just the whole point
that of my life I was always felt like I
was targeted to be abused in some way
um like uh
I always say like the quote of my life
is the beatings shall continue until
morale improves and
um it's just never stopped
um yeah it's led me to some dark places
you picked on in high school
oh God no I was the bullying high school
you know I was the bullying high school
and um I picked on the other kids I was
bullied as a little kid because we were
one of the poor kids in Trumbull because
we come from an affluent town
um and my family wasn't and like I said
we grew up my grandfather made us like a
little makeshift apartment in the
basement with the kitchen and a bathroom
in a bedroom for us kids
and that's where we grew up
um but we went to the Trumbull schools
and we always had like baskets of
clothes from the church donated to us we
never got anything new because my father
spent all the money on drugs
um he always worked he always had a job
but it was always him and his drugs
first he was a 70s
80s parent so that's just the way it was
back then for us and for a lot of kids I
think
um that are exers
so um in high school no that's where I
learned to do
um weed and Coke it was the 80s there
was a lot of weed and a lot of cocaine
and I took every opportunity to enjoy
myself but I was very book smart my
sisters are too
um but we were all Party Girls 80s party
girls and
70s 80s party girls I graduated in 89.
um I graduated high school we all
graduated high school we all went to
college
um somewhat I think my sister Hillary is
the only one that actually finished but
um we tried our best and we had each
other
um
my two sisters and I uh
had each other
um
to
kind of lift each other up and support
us while the abuse was happening
uh in my home in my childhood
so it was always us three we were knit
together so tightly because it was kind
of like us three against the parents or
not against Maybe
in defensive
um
and still to this day my sister is here
um still to this day is us three we're
very very very close
um
I don't think if I was the only child or
I don't know it just seems like one
without the other wouldn't make it
you were close I was blessed and my
mother
the poor little drunk housewife that she
was did bring us to church every day and
she was I mean every Sunday excuse me
and she was a Sunday school teacher and
she did honestly try her best to be a
good mother
you know she cooked and she cleaned and
um
but she wasn't good before noon so we
got up and got ourselves ready for
school and I got my sisters ready for
school and
nobody got us off the bus there was none
of that back in the day it was just um
basically she was up at noon and
and um
cooking and cleaning and being a mom
until probably
almost bedtime and but my father was so
violent towards my mother I mean she
surprised she lasted through that
11 years of marriage with him
tell me where your life went after that
you got married you had kids
oh God no 1989
um no I mean after that
oh when I when I grew up
um I got married yeah I was in America I
did get married
um when I was six months pregnant I was
31.
um
I don't like want a bad mouth my
ex-husband but he was exactly like my
father I mean even his mannerisms
it's hard to explain why we do that you
know and I never thought I had daddy
issues very common you know I never
thought that I had any kind of problems
or because I always was like oh I
survived I'm doing great and you know I
always had a job I always helped myself
together and I never became like a
full-blown addict you know it's just
like party time and at the club kind of
thing
um
so I thought I was okay and then I went
and I literally married my father I mean
like
it's uncanny that when I look back at it
now
they're the same person
it's uncanny it's the only
way I can describe it
very abusive
um
it's a horrible marriage I and
we were both wasted most of the time you
know I never did drugs when I was
pregnant I never drank when I was
pregnant and I was a good mom
I was an excellent mom and I sobered up
for a long time because I had my
daughter
but um
that wasn't perfect
um there was a lot of fighting and he he
was very abusive
to me not to my daughter but to me
got divorced
um
I don't even remember
when she was eight
she's 20 now so
so tell me about the story of the what
happened to you
the home invasion yes I was
43 I'm 51 now it was in 2015. my
daughter was in sixth grade and her and
I were living together
in the house I grew up in in Trumbull
um was Left To Us by my grandmother and
in her will
and um my daughter and I were living
there I was working as a paralegal in a
law firm in Norwalk Connecticut I had a
good job and
uh the house was I was fixing up the
house and and she was in a great School
in the schools that I was in when I was
younger and we were doing really well I
was sober and didn't do no partying was
over all that was over
um moved on from my ex blah blah blah
and it was like the first time in my
life that I was actually like
um considered myself to be like
100 stable you know like in every way
physically mentally emotionally
spiritually
um the only thing I was really praying
for was
when I had moved into the house with my
daughter is for God to get any kind of
sin out of my life like totally
um prune me or or
um teach me like more lessons go to the
next level because like I said I was
very healthy
um financially I was doing well
my daughter was thriving in school
and I didn't really have any problems so
the only thing I would wanted to really
was working at was getting to a higher
spiritual level I wanted to go into the
next plane of my spirituality with God
and so that summer on before the home
invasion I was really praying a lot to
God about that to take me to the next
level to help me see what I need to do
to progress spiritually to be closer to
God to have a closer relationship with
him
um
and
um all summer she would go to camp and I
would drop her off in the morning and I
would go to work in Norwalk and I would
open the office and I'd do my job
whatever blah blah blah come come back
and pick her up and then into the school
season in September October same thing
bring her to to school every day and um
go to work and
pick her up Aftercare and come home and
make dinner and go to bed and that was
our lives we had a really that whole
four or five months stress we we had a
really really
peaceful time together
um we were very close
um
I started noticing when I would come
home from work little things missing
uh like the change jar you know everyone
has to change jar or well the extras do
I don't know if the kids have it now but
uh we had to change jar and um
I noticed like my daughter had like the
little map and you put the quarters
because it's like all new state quarters
into the map and blah blah blah so I
thought Megan was taking the change from
Mommy you know so I kept saying Megan
where's all mommy's change you know Mom
I don't have it I don't know what you're
talking about I just blew it off I
didn't think that it was a big deal then
like little things like pieces of
jewelry little minor things you know
um we're missing
um
some of my
uh underwear were missing out of my
drawer I was like okay are these really
missing
or am I imagining this you know because
I have probably 100 Pair of
panties
so I'm like well maybe they're just in
the laundry like I would everything that
I would notice in my house that wasn't
there like I was thinking either Megan
was playing dress-up with my jewelry
playing with the change
um the underwear must be in the laundry
like I never put two and two together
that somebody was breaking into my house
during the day when I was at work and
Megan was at school
well he was breaking into five houses on
my street
um and he was actually breaking into one
of my best friend's house and he stole a
coin collection from her this I found
out after he was arrested
but um
on
um
the night that he came to get me
a week before it was on October 7th and
I was going to work at the law firm and
I don't like listen to any kind of like
religious broadcasts or radio or watch
any kind of religious TV
but for some reason like I heard on the
radio
um that Saint Maria
uh relics were coming from the Vatican
to Saint Teresa's Church on Main Street
in Trumbull you know it was like a big
deal
I had no idea who St Maria was never
been to Saint Teresa's Church I'm not
Catholic well I am I'm Irish Catholic
but it was I wasn't raised in the
Catholic church I was raised in the
Baptist Church
and I had this stuck in my head and then
I get to work and I Google it and you
know he has a St Maria's was on the town
website
so I'm like I have to get there
and I called my sister and I'm like
Bridget we have to go to St Maria's
relics tonight they're coming from the
Vatican and they're going to be at St
Teresa's in Trumbull she's like what the
hell are you talking about and I'm like
I don't know but we're going be at my
house at seven o'clock we're going
so she's like okay
um so me my sister and my daughter get
in the car drive this picture he says
there's a line out the door of all these
people waiting to see these relics and
people are coming out and they're like
this like
I got freaked out so we're looking at
each other like why are we here so we
just keep waiting it out we get into the
church we get into the line and there's
a TV
along the aisle St Maria was 11 years
old
and she was attacked by a man and
murdered and while she was being
attacked she was praying for the man's
soul to meet her in heaven
she was praying for Jesus to save this
man while he was killing her
so obviously she's the same I mean who
does that
so we go we're up to the relics and it's
like a coffin in her wax figurines in
there and her ashes are in that and they
give us little cards with St Maria they
say put the card up against the coffin
or the case or whatever it was and
um say a prayer whatever is in your
heart I don't remember what I prayed or
whatever but we all did it
and then we walked out and we were just
like it was awesome what an amazing
experience but I still had no idea why
we were there and then seven days later
I'm being attacked
by me and I didn't know
um
he
he had everything arranged the basement
door was broken open
he knew exactly where my bedroom was
he knew I had a daughter he knew where
her bedroom was he knew my house in and
out he came in through the basement
we were both sleeping in our rooms
upstairs
and and
um I must have heard something because I
woke up and I looked at my alarm clock
and I saw it was like 3 45 a.m and I was
like yes two more hours and I went back
to sleep
and um
then I feel I hear the door open and I
feel him crawl into bed with me
and I thought it was my daughter
having a nightmare and like kids come in
and just come into your bed so I start
pulling them into the bed and putting
the covers over top of them
and he's calls down on my breasts
like my daughter would do if she was
sick or had a nightmare
and he's holding me
and I start petting them you know like
when something happens to your kids and
you pet them you're like oh poor honey
you know and you're holding your pet the
back of their head or or rub their ear
or whatever to try to make them feel
better so I start petting them
on his head and then I start waking up
because I was sound asleep
and
um
I feel the cap
over his head
and it was over his head and it was
tucked in to his shirt
and I'm looking for my daughter's hair
and I go Megan Megan and I'm still my
eyes are still shut at this point and
he's here and I'm going why do you have
a hat on honey are you cold is that why
you you came to bed with Mommy are you
oh
are you sick are you cold
why
what happened what happened
um
why do you have a cap on and he just
kept on and said yes
and then I started feeling the arm
and then I felt the arm was around me in
the back and then I felt the gun in his
hand pressed on my back
and I said Megan honey honey why do you
have a gun
and he goes get up
and that's when I woke up
um and I woke up and I was sitting at
the edge of the bed trying to get my
bearings like
um trying to figure out like who was in
the bed
um
who's it where's Megan is somebody in
her bedroom
just like 100 thoughts and then he he's
sitting at the edge of the bed with me
and um he says told me to stand up and
I'm looking for my glasses because I
can't see anything without my glasses
I'm feeling my glasses and he goes no no
don't touch anything don't touch
anything just stand up and then he got
up behind me and put his arm around my
waist and pressed the gun to right here
to the back of my neck
um right in this very spot and he had
his hand like on my waist guiding me
right down the hallway right through my
kitchen right down my steps right out
the basement door which was open and
walking through my yard
so I'm like okay
somebody sent someone here to murder me
that was the first of course you know
that's what I was thinking
they're going to take me out back and
shoot me
um it could have been somebody from my
family because my grandmother had died
and everybody was fighting over the
estate
so that was like my first thought well
maybe somebody in my family is really
upset about us getting the house you
know and I was trying to rationalize it
and and I was talking to him and I was
asking him questions do you need money
do you need this do you need that
because I thought I didn't know he was
there to rape me I thought he was there
to murder me so I was trying to get him
tell me
why he was going to kill me and the gun
one of the worst things that I remember
was it kept slipping on the back of my
hair and it kept going like that and
kept going like that and I'm like oh man
this dude's gonna hit the side of my
face and blow off a whole sign of my
face and then I'm gonna look messed up
and my daughter's not going to want to
look at me anymore if I survive and I'm
walking around alive with have a face or
I'm not going to be able to have a uh
I'm not going to look pretty in my
coffin and you know it's just all this
stuff I just was for sure the gun was
going to go off because it just kept
slipping another thing I remember was
like
it didn't feel like a human being
was doing this to me it felt like an
evil presence
I can't explain it but felt like an evil
aura or Spirit was on top of me on top
of my back holding the gun against my
neck slipping the stupid gun
I feel like it's a stupid thing now that
I was worried about the gun
shooting my face
maybe maybe vain I don't know I mean
because I thought Megan wouldn't want to
look at me after that but
anyway
he takes me I have a really really
really big yard so he takes me out way
far in the back and he told me to get on
my hands and knees so now I'm like why
because I thought he was just going to
shoot me in the back of that it was
gonna be over with oh that's another
thing I thought I was like I'm Gonna Be
So Gangster about this because he was
like talking slaying like if you stare
scream I'm gonna blow your fm effing
handle off I'm gonna
so I was thinking in my head I'm not
going out like a [__]
if I'm gonna die I'm not gonna pee my
pants I'm not gonna get my hands and
knees and cry to this guy
I'm not gonna go out like that God give
me the strength to go out like a woman
to go out with Grace you know I don't
want to go out and have the guys come
pick clean up my clothes because I
pooped or feed all of myself I'm not
going out like that I'm gonna go out
strong and I stood upright and I was
like whatever I did and whoever's doing
this to me I'm gonna take it but I'm
Gonna Take It
bravely
and I made that decision and I think
that helped me through it a lot and then
when we got in the back
um and he he told oh first he told me to
take off my pants because I had pajama
pants on
um and a sweater because it was October
it was cold outside and first he told me
oh
um take off your pants and I'm like why
and he's like so I could see that
beautiful ass for myself and then I'm
like
this guy is going to rape me you know I
was like gross I was like completely
like I've been raped before so I know
but I was like oh I don't want to go
through this you know just shoot me in
the head get it over with I don't want
to go through it I don't want to do it
I don't want to do it I don't want all
the stuff that comes with it
foreign
but another thing to do there was the
stupid gun and then
um
pulled the pants down got on a fourth
he started doing what he needed to do
and I started collecting evidence
because now I figured out that he was
there to rate me and not murder me so I
started going he had gloves on
and in the jacket in the hood it was
completely covered because he was a
criminal he was already been robbing and
selling drugs and doing drugs and
killing people by accident and smashed
into this guy's car and killed him back
he's already in the system he's already
um a felon so he knew the routine so I'm
like well I'm a paralegal I start
thinking like a paralegal and then I
start thinking about oh he's here to
rape me well maybe he won't kill me
maybe he will I don't know who cares I
gotta get back to the house because what
if somebody's in there raping my
daughter right now
that was the tunnel vision
from then on
get collect evidence get back to my
house collect evidence get back into my
house save my daughter because if
somebody else is in there doing this
[__] to her
I need to stop it
um and I I came right into Focus
and I went inside his jacket and I
started going like this real nice and
soft on his arm like I was caressing him
you know just to get some kind of DNA
off of him
um
he did wear put a condom on and wear a
condom during the rape
how they got the DNA off my pajama pants
I don't know maybe it's Spilled Out of
the condom maybe he took it off I'm not
100 sure I can't remember every
detail the actual
sex that we had because I was too busy
kind of thinking about getting back into
the house
um
but I heard the condom wrapper in
him putting the condom on and
um he couldn't get hard so I had to help
him do that I had to reach behind
because he still had to think the gun
and I'd reach behind and and help him
out with that
and then uh yeah it was just insane but
anyway now I had to get back to my
daughter get back to my daughter so then
he must have put the kanama I don't know
he must have slipped up somewhere
because they did find and they said it
was a lot because I guess it takes a lot
of DNA hey evidence to get a um really
good profile you know
um it can't just be a little tiny bit
so
um I ended up uh oh yeah yeah I heard
the third at the end this is at the end
of the after he had sex with me and
everything and did what he had to do
um meanwhile just saying disgusting
it was vile
it was really vile
um
tell me how beautiful I am and it just
I don't I don't know I blocked a lot of
it out
um
but we were talking the entire time
he was speaking I was responding
um oh I was I started crying at one time
you told me to shut the [__] up not to
cry he didn't like that at all
the crying
so
I hear the thud go down because he must
have been doing something and getting
dressed or whatever and I heard the gun
the third of the gun and I got up and I
pulled my pants up and just ran
up my yard
to the basement door
and he's like
don't you dare call the [__] cops or
I'm gonna [__] kill you then kill
this one and your daughter and it's not
I know you're a mother you kept saying
I don't know what that means
but
I got in
and my daughter was standing in the
hallway with a pair of scissors like
this
just shaking with the scissors
I grab her
I bring her up to the Attic
I I tell her do not
leave the attic into the police drag you
out let them take you out because I
didn't know if anyone else was in the
house and I didn't know if he was going
to come back in and kill us
um so there there was this space where I
needed to get her safe and get the
police to the house
which was the hardest part
uh
I I could walk to my death
I can help this guy get a hard on while
he's raping me with a gun to my head
but getting my daughter to a safe place
and getting my mind together to get on
the phone and call the police and get
them to my house
was really really hard
um
she kept coming out of the attic and
turning all the lights on
and I kept putting her back up into the
attic and turning all the lights off
because I didn't want him to come and
get us and kill us or whoever else was
in the house you know I'm thinking there
could be Five Guys in here I didn't know
what was happening
then I start calling 9-1-1 and I live on
the Bridgeport Trumbull line did the
line of Two Cities my house is in
trouble across the streets in Bridgeport
901 kept going to the Bridgeport side
they wouldn't put me through I said
listen I just got rave time there's an
intruderies in my house I don't know
what else was here you know there's a
guy he has a gun that we can't help you
ma'am if you're calling from Trumbull
you have to call the Trumbull Police
Department
okay hang up I call 9-1-1 again same
thing goes to Bridgeport ma'am we cannot
help you
you have to call Trumbull Police
Department bridgeport's not going to be
dispatched to a Trumbull crime scene I'm
like I am on the floor laying on the
floor hiding from a gun
I don't know if this guy's in the
kitchen window gonna shoot my head off
I'm laying on the floor in the complete
darkness with my daughter now I'm
telling this to 9-1-1 ma'am we cannot
help you got to call Trumbull
I don't know the number to drama police
department off the top of my head so
third time I call again 9-1-1 I said put
me through the Trumbull police that's
all I said
and they did
so I don't know if the dispatch got sick
of me or whatever but they put me
through
and I'm like couldn't they do this two
phone calls ago
and I called the cops and the cops got
there and saved us
and the cops were uh
99 of the cops were great and they were
amazing and they saved Our Lives
um
I CR I stayed on the ground the whole
time because I just figured somebody was
gonna shoot us I just figured at this
point because I ran into the house and I
got away
that the killing was next
and and and that he was definitely going
to kill me the killing was coming either
him or somebody else and
um and so I crawled through my hallway
through my living room when I heard the
cops at the door
and I'm like are you the really the
police are you really the police it was
hard to get to that point from being
back in the house to get the police into
my house
I like all the trust was gone trust
issue I had trust issues I had all the
everything that comes with rape I had it
you know I came back into the house with
it and it [__] up my whole head [__]
up my thinking process it I couldn't
uh I didn't know what to do with my
daughter that's why I kept putting her
in the attic I mean I don't know if that
was the right thing to do or the wrong
thing to do
I was just trying to keep her safe
and I thought if she was me with me she
wouldn't be safe I don't know if that
makes any sense
she feels like I abandoned her left her
in the Attic
but that wasn't my reasoning
um
anyway
the cops came in they saved us and they
took me out of the house and I told them
that Megan was in the attic and how to
get up into the attic and they come up
come up and got her
and they put me in the back of a police
car and I'm freezing shaking and oh it's
not like in the movies where they put a
blanket around you and give you a cup of
warm tea no they throw you in the back
of a police car just whatever you're
wearing and I was wearing the same
clothes the pajama pants and the sweater
and then my daughter was wearing a pair
of shorts and a t-shirt and then they
throw her in the back of the police car
and she was laying on top of me shaking
ice freezing cold and shaking from
Terror and the police officer that's in
the car
is an [__] and he starts asking me
questions what do you what is the
problem here what happened with you
girls
and I'm like well this guy broke in my
house and raped me and this and then
he's like well why didn't you call us
before all this happened
I'm like I was sleeping in my bed
he said well why need your class when
the guy got in bed I go I didn't know
that
and he's like are you sure does any of
this even happen basically he called me
a liar in front of my child who had just
gone through this with me that killed my
my whole soul right there
um
because she just heard uh both be
accused of lying
um
I did under I did end up finding out who
he was and reported him and everything
and they reprimir into them but anyway
the rest of the police were amazing and
they called in the detectives from the
town next to us and they came in and and
gathered all the evidence but then when
I got brought they separated us and and
Megan had to go to the police station
with my sister and my ex-husband and I
had to go to the hospital and
um and the nurse was pissed because it
was chain shift and she's like oh I
gotta walk in first thing in the morning
and do a rape kit I'm really really not
up in the mood for this that's what she
said when she came into my hospital room
I was like sorry you know I didn't know
the seven to three shift you know I
didn't mean I didn't plan on being in in
the morning of your shift you know
because you got raped earlier yeah I'm
sorry I didn't get raped earlier my bad
or later when after lunch you know yeah
she was really pissed about the whole
thing and I was trying to explain to her
about my hand and what I was doing with
the arm she wasn't hearing that [__] she
went here yeah yeah
she was a real [__] anyway I did all
that and then I had to go through they
didn't they didn't uh they took my
clothes no no yeah yeah they took all my
clothes
um all I had was a Johnny coat and then
um I had no way to get home no but no
ride nothing to wear
um Rape Crisis missed it
the Center for Family Justice for they
they
weren't in good communication with the
police that day for whatever reason and
they they missed the call so nobody came
to like help me or anything
and um
all I wanted to do was take a shower and
get him off of me
and um I couldn't they wouldn't let me
take a shower they wouldn't give me
anything it was crazy and
um I called my sister I'm like could you
come get me
I want to go home and take a shower
so she didn't I go and I have and I'm
naked so she came and and brought me
some of her clothes because you couldn't
go into my house
and um
I got dressed in and had to go home and
go through the whole thing with the
detectives and show them everything and
they found some of his jewelry in the
backyard I must have knocked some of his
bracelets off
they had a lot of evidence and it was
good and you got caught and you went to
prison for 30 years for my case and and
that's all good and well but
my daughter and I have been divided ever
since that night
um completely
um ruined our relationship
completely removed ruined it
um why do you think that is
she told me
um she told me that she felt like I left
her in the Attic abandoned her in the
Attic
um
what are you supposed to do I I don't
know what I was supposed to do I don't
know
um
she just had like a really Harvard's a
real big resentment against me because
of it
um she doesn't remember the whole year
of sixth grade that was in October she
doesn't remember the whole entire year
none of it
um
all the kids on the bus made fun of her
in the next day
because I guess it got out that well
first of all when we were in the back of
the police car that morning
the school bus went by and saw all the
kids saw in the cop cars and all that
stuff so the next day when she got on
the bus to go to school
um because yeah she I got up and went
back to work she got up and went back to
school just like nothing happened and um
we were in shock and all the kids were
picking on her and she lost all her
friends because they were like oh our
mother saw the either the news or read
it in the paper or the police but our
mother told us that what happened to
your mother at that house and now we're
never going back there again you're not
our friend anymore so she was completely
shunned by all her friends that that she
had made at school
um
and we were just isolated for a very
long time
and
and ashamed and
horrified and that's what rape does to
you that's what it does to you and it
and it breaks you down
um it completely
it's so violent
and so evil
and so sadistic
that one something like that when you go
through that experience of rape
the evil and the sadisticness is so
heavy on you for such a long time it's
hard to get it off it's hard to get away
from it it's hard to just shake it off
get over it
like you're just
you're just in it it's very heavy
um
when I what made me want to do the
interview is when I see girls talk about
being prostitutes or you know um living
life on the streets or being involved in
games and this and that and the other
thing and they talk and their heads are
very high and they talk out loud like I
am right now and but when you talk about
rape you start shrinking
and your voice gets smaller
uh you know have you ever been raped
yeah
it it's like their whole demeanor
changes
it
it's a sh you live in it for such a long
time and you're living in [__] I mean
you're just living an evil pile of [__]
it's such a horrific thing it's such an
evil way to be violated as a woman or a
man or a child whoever as a human it's
such a vile thing to do to another human
being
I mean even to touch somebody that
doesn't want to be touched is vile but
never mind right and
you know you could be a prostitute or a
sex worker or this or that or on the
streets but you own that
that's your right but when you're raped
that is somebody taking from you they're
robbing you
okay it's not you're right it's not sex
it's a violent violent sadistic crime on
you and
it's been
since 2015 till now I think that's eight
years
um I know my mind doesn't work the way
it does with numbers and dates and stuff
anymore because I have PTSD but it's
been all these years and if you ask me
to sit here and talk about this years
ago there's no [__] way no way that I
would open my mouth
and if I did I would be talking like
this and I would be sobbing and crying
and and wrapped up like that because
that's how I used to talk about it I
would talk about it in the fetal
position crying and sobbing I think it's
so much for so many people to deal like
they can't even process it or deal with
it it takes years to process no but like
even people that you're telling the
story too they don't want to hear it
either it's just too too hard it's
disgusting I don't want to hear it I
don't want to hear I don't want to be me
I don't want to have to tell it I don't
want to tell other people about it but
it's important for the other victims
because the other victims know this
feeling and I want them to know that
you'll be sitting up straight you can
get back to yourself what helped you and
recover well help me recover was
um a lot of it was meditation
um the Bible
spirituality
um knowing that Saint Maria was put in
my life a week before the rape and I
feel that she was with me that whole
time and I I remember I even said to her
in my mind I I said um during the rape I
go Saint Maria I can't pray for this guy
right now
but
hopefully someday I will be able to be
like you
and I said that while he was having sex
with me so I did reach out to her I did
feel like she was there with me
um and the guy was caught how they could
how they catch him from the Connecticut
lab the DNA on my pajama pants
um you said there was a Chase
um no the chase was with David Anderson
um he this was be this is while he was
in this why he was in the system you're
not in the federal DNA system unless
they have your DNA for some reason
um but he was
um he he was being chased by the police
he
um my rapist was in a car and he hit
another car head on and killed that
driver a 21 year old kid from Seymour
Connecticut before he raped you before
he raped me so he was arrested and his
DNA was in his system huh he was already
convicted of a Murder
um vecular homicide or so I don't know
exactly what it was but
um uh yeah
I'm gonna side with a vehicle or
I don't know what the real charges
somebody died yeah yeah he was convicted
of it he was out on bond
it just blows my mind that the whole
thing
um he was on on selling drugs in Robin
houses you know that's how he came
across me you think he was just dumb
luck this happened to you no I don't
think it was dumb luck I think that um
that there was a disturbed 19 year old
in my neighborhood who was on drugs and
um desperate
uh and at a point in his life where um
he I I mean the police took his phone
and found on Google Maps all the houses
that he was going to during the day and
casing out and I think his his crimes
were just building and building and
progressing up higher and higher you
know he was getting more ballsy
and that's when he decided to rape me
he's like I'm gonna get this woman you
know I want to be with this woman or I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this crime or
whatever I think it was just another
like notch on his level of felons
um
I remember when the detectives came to
my home because they have to come to
your house and tell you when they find a
DNA match when they came to my home
and they came in and they said Eve we
found him we're going to arrest him
right now we're on our way to his house
his house was right down the street from
mine two blocks down lives with his
mother and his has five brothers and a
sister
beautiful family
beautiful family I met them in court
they were all praying for me
because he like I said he admitted that
he did it so and and they were all going
to church and praying for me
I didn't know that but that's amazing
that probably helped me recover but I'll
never forget when they came in and they
told me that um his name and that he was
19 and my first thought was oh my God
his poor mother
that's what I just I just said it right
out loud because I mean he is closer to
my daughter's age
and then closer to my age you know
because I was 43 she was 13. so the
first thought that came into my mouth my
head and out of my mouth was oh my God
his poor mother and his actors are going
no no screw them they're just scumbags
from Bridgeport they're just scumbag
low life support they're nobody they're
trash and I was like did you tell the
parent all I kept thinking about was the
poor mother you know and how I would
feel if
I had to go through something like that
I don't know why maybe it's just the
mother instinct in me but
um his family is beautiful but that's a
whole nother story
um
the how I got through it was definitely
uh my meditation coaches would tell me
oh every day we want you to put your
hand on your heart and say I love you
Eve and I was like [__] you no way I'm
not doing it there's no way in hell why
would I do something so stupid I don't
love myself I've never loved myself I
grew up in [__] I'll always be [__] and
I said but you know and then I thought
about it I went home and they kept
telling me this every week gone put your
hand on yourself tell yourself you love
me and I kept saying no and then finally
I I thought about it in meditation and I
said I thought of myself being a little
child
and um who I needed I saw something on
Facebook be who you needed when you were
little one of those stupid things you
know and and I thought about myself
pitching myself as two three years old
and my parents on drugs you know and and
um they would pass the join around in a
circle and I would go and pretend I was
smoking pot and I was the baby and
everybody laughed and thought was cute
and that's definitely not who I needed
when I was two and I put my hand in my
heart and I said I love you Eve as too
and that's where I started and I loved
myself and then I grew myself up every
day and I love myself more and more and
now I could do it every single day say I
love you Eve as me as a as a 51 year old
never thought I would be able to do that
rape or not never thought I would be
able to do something like that no way
and um
and I also came to realize that the when
when a woman or a girl or another or a
man whoever when somebody is raped you
are not yes it does break you down
but you are not broken the person that
did it to you
is the broken person
that's the person who is broken not you
you could put yourself back together
again forget about them whatever with
them but you could put yourself back
together with them you can recover
you can make your life better
I don't know how many times I tried to
kill myself and I have to have semicolon
butterfly tattoo and my sister has the
other half like this and I have the the
necklace my friend Diane
sent me from Amazon with the semicolon
because I just tried to drink myself to
death so many times after I was raped I
couldn't I went back to work but then I
couldn't go back to work because my eye
I broke my tear duct in my eye
from crying so hard during like night
terrors that I would cry so hard that um
I would go like that into my eye and it
broke my entire tear duct in my whole
face filled up my tears from the rape
and this was like two months after the
rape and my whole it was like a golf
ball over my eye so I couldn't go to
work anymore
um I had to have surgery where they put
a tube through your nose and drain it
and you got to keep the tube in your
nose through your eye for three months
so I couldn't work for a long time so I
just tried to drink myself to death
my daughter spent a lot of time at her
father's
but I don't do that anymore
because I'm
don't live in it anymore
yeah
it's a horrible thing to go through
just horrible
but it's it's something that you go
through
you don't have to live in it
you couldn't recover it's possible I
still struggle I still can't remember
things I probably didn't tell the story
right
but there's not just the event it's also
all the aftermath of it too the
aftermath is the worst
the event is probably the easiest thing
there were so many miracles that
are so
far beyond the darkness of it
St Maria thing and
the I love you thing
so much good that came out of it and my
daughter and I
our relationship is healing that's good
how many years did the guy get
he got 50 in total
um he got 30 just for mine
he probably would have gotten more for
David Anderson's but nobody came to
court for him you know what what his
parents didn't come to court for him or
anything
so nobody talked to the prosecutor it
makes a big difference too
if you don't report it and follow
through
and meet with the prosecutor and it's a
lot
to report go through I didn't want to go
through a rape kit
I've been through a rape kit before it
sucks
it sucks
and I didn't want to go to the police
station in and I didn't want to it's
hard all of it's hard
all of it is trauma the police are
traumatizing not all of them some of
them some of them were healers and
angels and I love them to this day they
cough in the nurse store you're horrible
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah but they're not
all they're
not all like that I had some really
um great detectives that helped me with
my case that came to court with me that
stood by me called me constantly checked
on me and my daughter I mean these guys
were amazing unbelievable there's a
couple rotten ones but there was
hundreds of good ones well you said 99
yeah 99
there was so so much goodness
in my life and
so many things I learned and it
definitely brought me to a higher
spiritual level like I had been praying
for I don't think it was dumb luck I
think that that this guy was out there
um robbing houses and casing houses and
stalking probably not just me probably
other women too but I was vulnerable it
was just my daughter and I and he knew
that I didn't have an alarm system I
didn't have a dog which I have now I
have an alarm system I have a dog no man
in the house
no men in the house right just me and
Megan so
I was vulnerable so I I think he picked
me because of my vulnerability I had a
big yard there was patches of woods and
that's how big my yard is that he can
hide out and and he made a path
through that to run home there's a path
to this day
um so
it was very convenient for him you know
he obviously knew I didn't have any
weapons I have a nine millimeter now and
a gun permit
and I am that the cops helped me obtain
of course and
and um
a baseball bat two baseball bats by my
bed with my nine millimeter and not that
not because I'm afraid just because I'm
not gonna because I could defend myself
now I could defend myself now
um and I and I don't live in in the best
area and
um and I'm
we're all still vulnerable and I've been
raped more than once I've been raped
many times and I've done uh I only have
done two rib kits and I've been raped
many times
um is there anything about your
demeanor your about you that would
attract
all of this all of that
um
no I think almost every woman has been
sexually assaulted in some way maybe
even every man I don't know but
um all my girlfriends have been sexually
assaulted in one way or another
and we come from a beautiful town in in
uh
essential assaults and it doesn't have
to be a full-blown rape with a gun to
your head you know um
it comes in a lot of it varies and it
comes along in different forms
um
and everybody
there was that me too thing I mean
even men
you know it's just a thing it's just the
culture of today
I don't want to be a victim of it
anymore
is there anything that anything good
that came from all of that
the good thing is that
um I could tell other women that they
don't have to be stuck in it forever
that I'm a living proof and I understand
how
[__] horrifying it is and you may
look at me and say oh look at her
there's nothing wrong with her she looks
fine to me
I didn't look like this eight years ago
I put on 30 pounds
30 pounds after my rate I lost 20 of it
but I put on 30 pounds
um I wouldn't wear my contacts I would
only wear my glasses kept my hair back
in a baseball cap wore baggy sweatpants
hid from the entire world for years this
went on
um didn't want anyone to look at me
um I hated myself loathed myself blamed
myself for not having a dog not having a
gun not pretending my daughter hiding
her in the Attic living in shame toxic
shame 24 7 and just looking at myself
like I was [__] because I allowed all
this to happen to me that's a [__]
lie
you know what I mean he's [__] he did it
it's his fault it's on him
I don't accept that responsibility
anymore he has to deal with it now in
his cell
I forgive him he was a stupid kid
I was in his path
I was just another victim in his path I
don't think he chose me I mean
um and and the other times that I was
raped
I was young
and it was by older boyfriends
you know and
um I just didn't defend myself
I didn't defend myself
um but
I
I love whom I love myself now
I've never loved myself
and if I didn't go through this
experience
I would still be hating myself and be 30
pounds
um big or at least 20 pounds bigger than
I am with my glasses on it my big
sweatpants and drinking my vodka
telling me myself that I'm [__] I'm not
[__] you're not [__]
it's a great example of what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger absolutely
and it's true it's the truth and I want
people to believe that
I know it's hard because I look okay now
like I have my [__] together and I'm
sober and I'm happy and I I'm living a
good life and I started my own business
and in um I take care of my daughter and
I do everything I'm supposed to do and
I'm a good mother and I'm a good sister
and I'm a good person all around and I
help the community and I've been
involved in a lot of charity work
um
but eight years ago I was just a pile of
[__]
living in shame
hating myself wanting to die
you wouldn't recognize me
there's hope there's hope
and I get it
that you're not in the same situation
I'm not in the same situation
but it's the same act of violence held
against us
don't let it destroy you
don't have to let it destroy you you
don't you can live you can survive
please believe me
all right Eve thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you I'm glad you're doing well
thank you